[موسيقى]
كان في توجه عند البعض حتى جمال عبد
الناصر وخالد محي الدين قالوا ان هم راحوا
للاخوان يعني ولكن ما قالوش ان احنا كنا
اخوانيين لكن راحوا عايز اقول دي كانت
ليست تهمه بقدر ما انه كان تيار موجود
لكن مؤكد انه الافكار افكار الشعراوي فيها
واخده من هذا الملح حتى فكره علاقته بالفن
خدها من حسن البنا من حسن البنا اه اللي
حسن البنا كان يقول ايه حلاله حلال وحرامه
حرام
[موسيقى]
لما بيقابلوه ما بيقولوش فن حرام او بطلوا
فن لكن بيقول لهم فن بمعايير معينه تقتل
الفن ده اللي انا بختلف فيه مع الشيخ
الشعراوي بحترمه كداعيه بحترم اجتهاده في
تفسير القران لكن بختلف مع مع الكثير من
افكاره
[موسيقى]
هل هو انتهج نهجا سلكه من بعده اخرون يعني
قصدي محاوله
الاستثمار في الفن او التاثير في الفن من
زاويه كمان اخوانيه او غير اخواني كان في
مجموعه فعلا كان لها اراء كتير بيطلعوا
منه يتحجبه او يبطلوا او يقول لك نعمل فن
ملتزم وهكذا يعني كان في حاجات كتيره اثرت
على
[موسيقى]